I'm going to show you how important
delivery of a message is one is how you
raise or lower your voice I always cue
it by tilting my head I'm like huh what
are the main things increase my voice at
the end there an improperly trained
salesp person might be like well what
are the main concerns you have and all
of a sudden that sounds like a very
different thing so they're saying the
script but the prospect isn't hearing
the same message and the second is where
you choose to emphasize if I say I
didn't say he hit his wife if I say it
like that I have neutral Tone If I say I
didn't say he hit his wife then it's
like I'm not saying that I didn't say he
hit his wife is now saying that like
those weren't my words I didn't say he
hit his wife he's the one to question I
didn't say he hit his wife means like he
might have done something else but he
did something to his wife I didn't say
he hit his wife it could have been
somebody else's I didn't say he hit his
wife it might have been his kid